okay I am still traumatized today I'm
trying to get past and trying to move
past it but what happened was over over
the weekend we were we were going to
load the kayak into the truck so we
could bring it to the lake so I could
fish in the kayak one of my favorite
things to do is to go fishing in a kayak
and which really just means that I'm too
cheap to buy a boat but we're about to
load it in the cut in the in the truck
and then we noticed a spider in the
kayak and it was not just any spider as
a black widow spider which had laid
there was an egg sack there was a black
widow spider and an egg sack in the kite
now that's literally my nightmare I mean
in a very literal sense that is my
nightmare that is my worst case scenario
well I guess worst-case scenario is that
we don't notice it I get into the kayak
and then I'm out in in the lake and then
the black widow spider jumps out and
tries to bite me in the eyeballs that's
the worst case this is like very close
to the worst case scenario and anyway
what could I do then in that situation
aside from burn the kayak burned the
truck burned my house burned myself I
jumped into the fire myself I look
pretty good afterwards considering and
so now I can never kayak again and I can
never walk out of my house ever again
now you might say that it's very girly
of me to react this way to a spider I am
terrified of spiders I admit but I would
respond to that in two ways number one
how dare you
sexist number two spiders are actually
demons they are from Hell they crawled
out of the cracks in the ground from
hell and that's I mean it's in the Bible
that's it's it's right there so he might
girly because I don't want to be around
demon spiders and my girly because I
don't want them to crawl into my ears
and eat my soul as spiders are known to
do no that's just called taking
precautions okay that is that's called
knowing the science all right
I'm gonna try to move past this and talk
about other things today as best I can
to overcome the trauma and what we're
going to do is to begin with I want to
talk about something that if you're a
die-hard Trump supporter a die-hard
Trump fan you're probably not going to
like but I think you especially need to
hear it so I hope you hope you stick
through it
with me so we can have this conversation
but first before we get into that a word
from our friends at noon you know
getting in shape is not just about
losing weight it's it's about learning
healthier habits feeling better about
yourself whether that's more stamina so
you can kind of keep up with your with
your busy life keep up with the kids
keep up with your job or if it's getting
into the the genes you've wanted to
we're being more in tune with your
body's needs whatever it is that's what
it's about the great thing about Noom is
that it can help you in a very
personalized kind of specific way no
matter your situation or your health
your fitness goals whatever it is so for
me in my very specific situation it's
been great because I'm immobilized for
the most part with my achilles injury
and now I'm even more immobilized
because of my fear of spiders and so
that means I can't do a lot of the kind
of cardio stuff I like to do usually and
that's where the more well-rounded
approach by Noom helps out keeps me from
becoming a blimp as I am as I am you
know incapacitated in some ways so I
really need to focus on eating healthy
developing good habits and Noom has been
great for that Noom is a habit changing
solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses based in
psychology Noom is all about kind of
teaching you why you do the things that
you do which will then help you break
bad habits and form good ones new ms
it's not just a diet it's a it's it's a
healthy and easy to stick to way of life
you don't to change it all in one day
small steps make the big difference sign
up for your free trial today at noon n o
o m.com slash Walsh you don't have to
change it all in one day small steps
make a big difference so sign up for
your trial today at noon n oom comm
slash Walsh what do you have to lose
visit new mcoms slash walls to start
your trial today that's Noom comm slash
Walsh the last weight loss program
you're gonna need okay now for a
conversation that is sure to upset
Trump's biggest fans I think but it's a
conversation that if if you're in that
group I think as I said
you need to be a part of first though
let's kind of set the stage well back up
last week was a pretty disastrous week
for the Democrats as we discussed last
week
AOC basically insinuate Alexandre Kaiser
Cortez basically insinuated that Nancy
Pelosi is racist accusing her of quote
singling out women of color in Congress
which is not so much in the insinuation
of racism as it is an outright
accusation of racism and then Pelosi
responded and their supporters and the
different factions have been going back
and forth eating each other alive it's
been very ugly ugly if you're a Democrat
if you're you know not a Democrat if
you're a conservative it's kind of
beautiful to watch your opponents eat
themselves and then over the weekend so
that was what happened last week the
Democrats spent last week eating each
other cannibalizing you know their own
party and then we get to the weekend at
over the weekend left-wing extremists
have been themselves going out of their
way to expose themselves as the
anti-american militants that they really
are their way there were two moments
first there was this moment watch this
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
those are leftist protesters at an ice
facility in Colorado ripping the
American flag down and replacing it with
a Mexican flag and I have to tell you
I'm very glad they did this I'm not glad
to see that the the the the flag
disrespected but I'm glad I'm always
glad when leftist radicals exposed
themselves as the radicals they are I'm
glad when they make their true
intentions known I'm glad for the truth
to be shown and for people to see it
they really do hate this country and
they really do want to bring illegal
immigrants in here in order to upend and
destroy our country that's very clear I
mean that's that's what that the
symbolism there means we tear down an
American flag and replace it with a
Mexican flag that's what you're doing
then also on Saturday something I was
not glad about because of the violence
and the fact that someone died in the
process and antifa terrorists waged an
attack at a nice facility in Washington
State he came with explosive devices a
gun and he was eventually thank God he
didn't he didn't succeed in hurting
anybody at the ice facility but he
himself was shot and killed by police
this is an incident that should get a
lot of attention now we know that the
the mains did leftist media is going to
ignore it but this is you know it
someone deeply affiliated with and
involved in an Tifa someone has been
arrested in the past who's going now
with a gun and incendiary devices and
attacking a government facility
I mean and Tifa is a terrorist
organization and that is becoming
increasingly clear and they themselves
the antifa members are increasingly less
shy about you know acting like
terrorists and exposing themselves as
terrorists so we should be talking about
that we should be talking about the flag
thing we should be talking still about
Democrats you know the infighting and
everything but we haven't been talking
much about that this weekend because
instead we've been talking about Donald
Trump's tweeting a Donald
has a policy it seems where he will not
let his enemies destroy themselves for
very long
yeah when his enemies are destroying
themselves Donald Trump just
compulsively needs to jump in and say
ditto put some of the negative spotlight
on me I'm not gonna let you guys make
idiots of yourselves okay I'm still here
he needs to bring the spotlight the
negative spotlight back on himself he is
constantly constantly constantly bailing
out his opponents by saying dumb stuff
that gives them an excuse to change the
subject and get back to talking about
him in a negative way constantly he's
constantly doing it and he did it again
in a big way this weekend referring to
what is annoyingly now I guess called
the squad you couldn't think of a more
annoying name for these for the for this
collection of people but the the
freshmen Democratic representatives who
have been warring with Pelosi lately and
who have been you know getting all the
just sucking all the air out of the room
and getting all the attention it's Oh
Ilhan Omar Alexandre Kaiser Cortez
Rashida's liebe and Jana Jana Presley
okay those are the sort of the four
representatives that are in this
unofficial group now and referring to
them Trump tweeted this he said so
interesting to see progressive Democrat
Congresswomen who originally came from
countries whose governments are complete
and total catastrophe the worst most
corrupt and inept anywhere in the world
if they even have a functioning
government at all now loudly and
viciously telling the people the United
States the greatest the most powerful
nation on earth how our government is to
be run why don't they go back and help
fix the totally broken and
crime-infested places from which they
came then come back and show us how it's
done
these places need your help badly you
can't leave fast enough I'm sure that
Nancy Pelosi would be very happy to
quickly work out free travel
arrangements that last line about Nancy
Pelosi makes it very clear who he's
referring to there's no way around it
he's referring to the Congress women who
Nancy Pelosi has been at odds with and
those are the four that I mentioned so
there you have it he is telling minority
women to go back where they came
from the it's just that's what's
happening here there's no way around it
he said it's it's right in there I mean
you could try to deny it's not what he
said we can all read it it's right there
we know what he said that is what he
said plain as day and we should also
mention to make matters worse that only
one of the four women is foreign-born
Omar is is foreign-born but the others
were born in the United States so you
know some Trump fans have tried to bail
out the president by saying oh no he was
only referring to Omar not the other
ones well that's nonsense he said women
that's plural he and he's continued to
tweet on this subject just continuing to
keep it you know to make sure that we
continue talking about it and he's he
always talks about it in a plural he's
not he's not just talking about Omar
he's talking about all four of them it's
very very clear now again as a Trump fan
you could deny it you can tell each
other and your cell that's not what he
meant but everybody else knows what he
meant and no matter what you say you're
not gonna change what other people know
to be true you see that that's the
problem so he is he is also telling
people who were born in this country to
go back where they came from now the
other rationalization I've heard from
some Trump fans to say oh no it wasn't
saying go back to the countries where
they originally came from or their
families camera but go back to their
districts as Congress people go back and
fix it he said countries he literally
said countries he started the thing by
talking about countries they came from
and then he said go back so clearly yes
he is telling these people who are again
only one of them is actually
foreign-born to go back where they came
from you can't get around it you just
can't it and it is he's telling minority
women to go back where they came from
which is a monumentally stupid thing to
say such an absolutely dumb ridiculous
idiotic unforced error that can only
hurt him and the Republicans and
conservatives it cannot do anything good
there's nothing good that can come of it
period
surprised by it because Trump as I said
is constantly doing this kind of thing
he's constantly getting his message
across in the worst possible way and
stepping on every landmine in the
process and seemingly determined to make
sure that he confirms all of the worst
things that he is that is that his
enemies say about him
this tweets like so many of trumps
tweets he's a gift to omar cortez all
the gut all the democrats it is it is
like it's like a christmas present that
he wrapped up and handed them and said
here you go it takes the focus off of
them it gives them reason to unite what
they were they were at each other's
throat now they're united now they're
back together again and they're
happy-go-lucky and you know they're in
this fight together so that's not good
it's better when they're fighting it's
that you don't want them together united
it gives them a chance to take a
righteous stand and stand against racism
and ethnocentrism it gets them all that
it gives them campaign material fogger
it's it's just it is as I said a gift
now look I don't think that Trump is
racist I've said that many times
Trump no he's not see his enemies either
knowingly misrepresenting which of
course we know they do or they just
really don't understand also I think
there are a lot of people his fans
included actually who really just don't
understand somehow what he's all about
no I think Trump is very easy to read
he's very you know he's a very simple
person to understand what makes him tick
so is he racist no Trump just says stuff
that's what he says whatever will get
him attention he doesn't hate people
based on race he likes anyone who likes
him we're period if you like him and say
something nice about him he will like
you it doesn't matter who you are it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter and and
if you criticize him he hates you it's
as simple as that it's a race doesn't
factor in gender doesn't factor it's a
political party doesn't factor in
nothing factors and that's it that's all
there is to it it's that simple
it's also true that the left and and
and you know Democrats leftist they're
gonna call people racist regardless
they're gonna call their enemies racist
regardless I get called racist all the
time
erroneously but I get called it it's
just a word that the left throws around
and it is a word that that talk about on
for stupid errors on their part they
have taken this accusation which which
could have a lot of force to it and used
to have a lot of force but now it
doesn't have as much because they use it
way too often and they call everything
racist and the thing is when you call
everything racist and then you actually
stumble across a racist thing it's gonna
be harder for you to condemn it or to
have people take your condemnation
seriously because your cuts the boy who
cried wolf thing boy who cried racism
right so yes so those two things should
be stipulated fine with that said
however the fact is he told minority
women to go back where they came from
and it is really really really really
really easy to credibly paint that as a
racist comment now here's the nuance
here again you know if you're a Trump
fan you can say he's not racist but he
fine it is clearly very very easy though
to take a comment like that and present
it methought at is racist now yes they
do that with every comment sure but you
don't have to hand it to them on a
silver platter okay you don't have to do
that you don't have to put yourself in a
situation where you're trying to argue
you know you could tell minorities to
come back where they came from and is
not racist let me explain why that's a
losing conversation that's not a winner
and it's stupid white we don't need to
talk about that that's not the point
that's what frustrates me so much is it
you know people say oh well you know
he's talking about immigration it's like
okay let's talk about that we don't need
to have a conversation about well is it
technically racist to tell people no
that's not the freaking point you think
that it's hell
fool to have that conversation you think
it you think it will get our point
across better you think we're more
likely to UM bring people to our side
when when we're trying to you know have
the conversation through that lens I
mean it's like the thing where he said
you know there are fine people on both
sides after the neo-nazi rally of
Charlottesville now Trump fans again
will are very quick to point out that if
you look at it in context that's it's
not what he said he wasn't referring to
the neo-nazis he was trying to say that
there were other people there who were
not neo-nazis who were there for the
reasons and and that they could be fine
people I get that okay I yes that's true
you look at it cut but it was still a
stupid thing to say it we don't want to
have to sit here and explain why well
yeah you could say there are five people
on both sides in reference to a mostly
neo-nazi rally and it's not technically
racist that might be true but it's a
losing conversation it's a loser it's
just there's no reason to say it he
should have just not said it and it's
not because I you know every time I talk
about this people say oh you just want
to be politically correct come on you
know you know me right I'm not
politically correct I could care less
about political correctness
I say things every day that are as as
far for politically correct as humanly
possible and I have the death threats
and the the death wishes and the hate
mail and everything imaginable to prove
it okay I've told you about it on the
show that people wish death and worse on
my family on my children on me it's a
normal occurrence for me death wishes
death threats I mean all that stuff okay
because I don't care about political
correctness and because I'm you know I'm
going to engage on issue so I don't care
about that that's not my point
but if I'm talking to minorities and
we're debating something I'm not gonna
say go back where you came from but
because I'm politically correct know
it's just an incredibly stupid way of
getting your point across and you're
gonna lose it once you say something
like that you lose any chance you had of
conveying your message and actually
getting it across is gone because you
said that okay there's a there's a now I
do think you can say something like and
I have said things like generally
speaking not targeted at minorities but
just in general look if you hate America
that much if you think it's a damn good
then you can leave right I've said that
about Colin Kaepernick but there's a
very clear difference actually between
saying look if you hate America you can
leave and saying go back where you came
from it's a very clear difference
between those two statements very clear
and anyone who cannot see the difference
shouldn't be in politics if you can't
see the difference between those two
things
you are not nearly politically savvy
enough to be in politics now Trump fans
will still try to pretend that the
president tells it like it is and you
know says the things that other people
are afraid of saying that's not it okay
I mean at this point guys you got to see
the reality for what it is it's just
it's the same thing when you still hear
people trying to claim that Trump is
playing some sort of brilliant game of
3d chess and this is all a political
strategy and now it's so it's it's so
you know subliminal and subtle and yet
it it's so Jake the guy's a genius
no no I mean by now you must realize
what's going on he watches Fox and
Friends especially on the weekend and he
just tweets and thinks out loud on the
internet that's it that's all it I mean
it's like a lot of people on Twitter
except he's the president it's that
that's that's the difference here now
you could say about me oh if you run
your mouth on Twitter all the time true
I do but I'm not the president though
you see I'm just paid to run my mouth
that's that's my whole job I'm not paid
to run the country I am paid to run my
mouth it's a and it could be a fun job
and you know
we can argue about whether or not it's a
very useful job but regardless that's my
job
I like to think the president his job is
bigger than that more than that and even
as someone who's paid to run my mouth
even I wouldn't say half of the stuff
that he says on Twitter again not
because I'm afraid not because I'm
politically but but because it's stupid
to say and will achieve nothing positive
at all period so ok here's here's the
point we gotta we gotta move on when it
comes to the tweeting if if you if you
are a die-hard fan you love the tweets
great fine I mean you're you're entitled
to love the tweets I'm not telling you
not to you can think whatever you want
right but most people in the country are
not diehard Trump fans and there aren't
enough of you to reelect him in 2020
it's it's just not enough now he won in
2020 with three million fewer vote
voters and he did it because he was
running against Hillary Clinton who's
the most unlikable and corrupt political
candidate in modern American history
she didn't campaign in the Rust Belt
amazingly she was being investigated by
the FBI
during the campaign he was a novelty at
the time which which which really counts
for something and his the people who
didn't like him his opponents didn't
take him seriously enough as a threat
and so they didn't show up in places
like Detroit in Philadelphia is a lot of
these urban centers there was a
depressed voter turnout partly because
they thought I was gonna lose anyway
went off to take him seriously well as
soon as he won they realized that oh
wait okay that was a mistake and then
that's why it was it was just a few
weeks later after he was inaugurated or
was a few weeks before I remember where
he had the women's March he had a
million people out and they were you
know freaking out about Trump now and we
all said at the time okay it's a little
late for that you people should have
been there you know if you really were
that worried about Trump maybe you
should have showed up at the ballot box
and you didn't they're not going to make
that mistake again
they won't you can't
you cannot count on on Trump's opponents
and people hate him not showing up again
they will show up so all those things I
just listed those are benefits he is not
gonna have anymore those are gone it's a
different day it's a different year
different which which yet again
emphasizes that he's going to need to
expand his coalition now he won with
what was a 60 or 61 million voters last
time yeah it's all about the electoral
college right but it also you also need
bodies you need warm bodies that's how
you get the electoral college votes so
he won with that amount last time um
that same amount isn't gonna be enough
this time and it's arguable it's it's
doubtful whether he could even get that
mitt the same amount again but you have
to ask what has he done to expand the
base to get more people in and don't
just tell me how the economy is doing
fine who cares I Got News for you most
people don't vote based on the economy
that whatever anyone says it's not true
most people don't most people they're
not looking at the freakin stock market
before they go to the polls no what has
he done in terms of his communicating in
terms of hitting on a very human level
right what is he doing to expand to
bring more people in because running his
mouth on Twitter the same way he did in
2015 in 2016
does that represent an attempt to bring
more people in to appeal to more people
are these tweets going to appeal to more
people no that's the problem
you know they've done surveys on this
the vast majority of Americans have a
negative view of the tweeting and if
they did a survey on that particular
tweet I guarantee the majority are gonna
say I don't like it now they might not
all freak out and say it's racist but at
best they're gonna say that was stupid
and worse they're gonna say he's a bigot
racist Klan member right that's kind of
the scale you're good when you say stuff
like that that's the best you can hope
for is for people to say that's stupid
but I'll try to look past it and that's
what Twitter has become it's become a
thing where at best
people look past it it's not a net
positive anymore and here's how I know
and then we'll move on
here's how I know that it's not an it's
not a net positive because I think we
all know and I talk to people like this
all the time people who are kind of more
in the middle politically they like some
of trumps policies in fact policy-wise
he's he's better than they thought he
would be so they liked him as boss and
they don't like some others but they're
kind of like you know they don't like
the Democrats either and there's a lot
of people in that realm don't like
Democrats not diehard Republicans not
diehard Trump fans they like some of
those policies they're with them on some
of most of the immigration stuff that
with among the gun rights stuff that
with them on you know foreign policy but
they really hate the tweets and they
read they did his whole act as whole
shtick they just hate it they don't like
it they are turned off by it they're all
and so there are a lot of people in that
camp now some of them are gonna overlook
it and vote for him anyway great but not
all of them will there are gonna be some
who say you know what I just I can't
vote for we're gonna stay home you just
I'm just so sick of it
or maybe lavota against them who knows
you might not agree with that fine but
those people exist that's a political
reality so we know those people exist I
talk to them all the time I know they
exist
do you think there's anyone who the same
sort of thing where they say yeah you
know I like or you know let's look
anything yeah they kind of are if the
honest policies and I don't know they're
sort of they're sort of in the middle
but they just love the tweets it's like
give me more tweets I love this stuff
man
and so they're gonna be more inclined to
vote for him because of the tweets you
think there's anyone in that category if
you're a die-hard fan you're not in that
category I'll talk about you I'm talking
about people are not die-hard yet are
gonna be more compelled to vote for him
because of the tweeting I think we all
know there's nobody in that category
there are a lot of people who maybe
would vote for them are less are
less excited about it because of the
tweets there's nobody who are a maybe
but are more excited because of the
tweets and so that tells us that it's
just it's a it's it's not good
politically it's not good and he's
killing himself and he's giving gifts to
the Democrats and if you if you really
are a trump supporter and if you really
hate the Democrats you don't want to in
control you got to stop encouraging this
stuff because it's not helping alright
let's see what else you want to talk
about let's go back let's go back
briefly and I talked about the Democrats
embarrassing themselves let's look at
one of the embarrassing Democratic
moments that Trump has so helpfully
distracted us from Alexandria okay Joe
Cortez at a hearing on Friday tried to
take the former head of ice to task in
fact before we play that clip it's a
great clip before we play that actually
she so she was she was at this hearing
and first of all she insisted on being
sworn in even though she was told well
you don't need a sworps where people
Aaron we don't swear people in for this
she insisted on it and why did she
insist on being sworn in well because
she stood up there and she you know she
had her she had her hand up and she had
this you know that kind of like innocent
but but sort of innocent deer in the
headlights but also determined sort of
facial expression that AOC does all the
time so she's standing there with that
facial expression with her hand up and
the reason why she insisted on being
sworn in even though it wasn't necessary
is so just so she could get that picture
and just so that now she knew that she's
going to get that picture of herself
with her hand up and then every news
article about the hearing is gonna have
that picture attached to it which means
that okay now she looks determined and
serious and it's a nice little picture
and also it makes it about her now I I
think that that's a disingenuous tactic
I think using you know using a
swearing-in as a as a
you know as a political ploy like that
is detestable it actually that's
actually taking the Lord's name in vain
that's actually what taking the Lord's
name in vain means when you swear by
something but you don't mean that you're
doing it in vain so I don't like it but
it's politically savvy now see that's
what politically brilliant move looks
like and aoc I I don't like her I mean I
think her policy wise I absolutely
oppose everything she's ever said or
suggested policy wise and as a person I
think she's dishonest
I think she's she's she's a race baiter
I just I don't like her as a person I
don't think she's a good person but she
she she is politically savvy and that
was a there's a pretty brilliant move
see that's the kind of thing Trump needs
to be doing not that exact thing but
things that are gonna make you look good
things that you know I just where you
think about how this is going to be
perceived and viewed by the general
public not just your diehard fans but
just the average person who doesn't
follow politics that closely and the
average person doesn't follow it they're
gonna see the picture of aoc with their
hand up I guess I know that's a very
it's like a very honest and
straightforward person who's swearing in
its gonna tell the truth that's what
these sort of just average oblivious
persons gonna think Trump needs to be
doing a lot more to appeal to that type
of person or he's gonna lose okay so she
that was a fine little stunt but then
the problem is you could do the stunt
for the picture but then yeah then it
comes time for the actual substance and
that's where ALC falls apart and so here
she is
you could tell she she thinks she's got
him but she doesn't watch this mr.
Holman your name is on this is this
correct yes I sign that memo so you are
the author of the family separation
policy I'm not the author of this memo
you're not the author but you sign the
memo yes a zero-tolerance memo so you
provided the official record
and a Shinto secretary Nielsen on family
for the United States to pursue family
separation
I gave secretary Neilson numerous
recommendations on how to secure the
border and save lives but it says here
that you ret you gave her numerous
options but the recommendation was
option three family separation I'm
saying this is not the only paper where
we given the secretary numerous options
to secure the border and save lives and
so the recommendation of the many that
you recommended you recommended family
separation I recommend a zero tolerance
which includes family separation the
same as is whatever US citizen parent
gets arrested wouldn't wear the child
zero tolerance was interpreted as the
policy that separated children from if I
get arrested for DUI and I have a young
child in a car I'm gonna be separated
when I also police office in New York
and I arrested a father for domestic
violence I separated that all due
respect legal asylees are not charged
with any crime when you're in the
country illegally is violation eight
United States Code 1325 seeking asylum
is legal if you want to seek assignment
go to the port of entry do the legal way
the Attorney General the United States
has made that clear okay okay so there
you there you go you know what that is
that is appeals to emotion appeals to
feeling talking points all of that in a
bundle
coming right up against just facts and a
logical point of view that the ice
director their former ice director what
he it's just a lot just common sense
logical look here's the deal type of
approach and when the when the one
appeal smashes up against that it's like
a brick wall and it just falls to pieces
and so she just decided that was just a
beautiful moment because she just
disintegrated she had all of her she had
all of her her talking points oh you're
separating families and he says yeah
it's what happens when you arrest
somebody of course we are that's not the
point okay it's not it's this isn't some
ploy some you know when when if you get
arrested for DUI or something you have
your kids in the car you're gonna be
separated from your children and you're
also gonna be locked in a cage and if
you want to put it like that of course
it's gonna make it seem worse but it's
actually just it's a it's a what else
are you gonna do you're gonna put the
kid and in jail with the parent that
would be a heck of a lot worse than
separating them but when you're in a
position where you've got somebody
breaking the law and you need to detain
them there isn't any sort of happy or
nice way to do it it's it's kind of a
lose-lose regardless a lose-lose for the
person especially who's being arrested
and if they've got kids if they got a
family it's just gonna make it even more
difficult but you still have to enforce
the law obviously so I love that
approach that's a good approach because
look it's he wasn't showboating he
wasn't trying to be intentionally
outrageous or provocative or anything he
was just like here's the deal all right
um I guess we're gonna well I've got a
bunch of emails I don't have time to get
into us I think we'll save them I also
wanted to mention I think it's September
I want to say September 20th I don't
look it up but there is this Facebook
group which I can't tell if it's serious
or not I can you can't tell anymore
especially online if people are being
serious or if they're just crazy I mean
for the longest time I the whole Flat
Earth thing there's a flat earth groups
online and Flat Earth YouTube people for
the longest time I really thought that
all that stuff was ironic and people
were just kidding around and it was just
sort of this inside joke and so I
thought I could appreciate that I can
appreciate irony and and then it took me
a while before I realized oh wait
they're serious people actually believe
this so it's a similar thing here where
you've got a Facebook group with that I
don't know what the number is up now but
thousands of people who are claiming
that they plan to storm area51 out in
the desert and I believe what is it
Nevada area 51 they plan to storm it so
that they can discover the aliens that
they believe are being kept at area 51
the Facebook group this the the
description says let's get them aliens
and it suggested that if they all run
and they charge area of if you want then
they can't all be shot the the bullets
won't be able to keep up with them which
of course is not true I just would tell
you that so as I said I don't know I
don't know if it's I can't tell these
people are sincere or not I hope they're
they aren't because if a thousand people
do storm area51 you're gonna have a
thousand dead people and nobody wants to
see that and I and I'll also say this
listen as as fun as it is to think that
aliens have visited earth and the duck
the government is hiding you know the
information about these aliens as it's I
like to think about to think that that's
true too because it's a fun thing to
think it makes you feel like you're
living in a movie but I got to tell you
if you're planning on storming area 51
I'm just spoiler alert
they don't have aliens which as far as
you're concerned they're definitely not
gonna have aliens because you're gonna
be killed in the process so that you'll
never see them even if they do have but
in any case they don't have them they
don't have the aliens and I know that
for two reasons number one this is the
main thing and this is one of the
reasons why all the conspiracy theories
about how they did that the government
did 9/11 the government faked the moon
landing the government all this stuff I
know that all of that is false because
number one is just self-evidently absurd
and stupid and I have common sense but
number two our government is not nearly
competent enough to coordinate these
conspiracies and
keep all these secrets I mean you see
how things are just leaking out of the
Trump administration constantly out of
every presidential administration there
are constant leaks and everything
happening you really think I mean area
51 has been there for four decades so
that means that thousands of people
probably not only know about the aliens
but I've seen the aliens and at this
point there's been no leaked information
no no video or photos have made it out
now just our government again is not
nearly competent enough to keep a secret
like that for so long
and then number two also I do think
there are aliens out there but they have
never made it to earth
they never will the distances are just
too great there is no technology means
in science fiction there's technology in
reality they're just probably cannot
ever be technology that would traverse
the distances you would need to traverse
in order for one civilized planet to
encounter another civilized planet I
mean we're talking about light-years
traveling at the speed of light is
impossible traveling beyond speed of
light is definitely impossible but even
if you were traveling at the speed of
light which again is impossible it would
still take you probably hundreds of
years in a spaceship to get to a planet
that potentially has other intelligent
life it's never gonna happen
so we're alone as far as as far as we're
concerned we are alone on earth don't go
getting yourself shot over it I
understand the appeal not of getting
shot but of wanting to see area 51 but
don't do it that's my recommendation all
right we will leave it there thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed hey everyone its
Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin
show our president Donald Trump is
acting like a jerk again the never Trump
errs clutch their pearls the pro Trump
errs thump their chests but with the
Democrats swiftly becoming an
anti-american anti freedom anti
prosperity party
we need Trump to win in 2020 so it's
wise to ask how much jerk is too much
jerk we'll ask on the Andrew Klavan show
I'm Andrew Clavin